is a news conference underway let's
listen came to our city this morning to
exercise their first amendment rights
and were largely concentrated in the
area of the national mall
following the president's remarks a
large crowd began to march
eastbound on madison avenue northwest
and constitution avenue northwest
as the demonstrators approached the
united states capitol grounds
there was a noticeable change in their
demeanor
they breached the fencing along the u.s
capitol grounds
and confronted police lines surrounding
the building
mpd was requested by the united states
by the united states capitol police
to provide assistance with crowd
management
and due to the violent behavior towards
the police officers there
and their intent on gaining access to
the to the capitol
a riot was declared it was clear that
the crowd was intent on causing harm
to our officers by deploying chemical
irritants on police
to force entry into the united states
capitol building
as you are aware they were able to gain
access to the capitol building
and i con can confirm that one civilian
was reported to have sustained
a gunshot wound inside of the capitol
details of the shooting are not
immediately available and the situation
remains under investigation the
metropolitan police department
will be taking the lead on that
investigation mpd continues to provide
personnel resources and assistance on
the grounds
of the u.s capitol and has requested the
assistance of law enforcement partners
through a previously in place mutual aid
agreement
as you heard from the mayor a 6 pm
curfew has been put in place tonight
and will be in effect until 6 a.m
tomorrow
january 7th we are advising everyone
everyone that is not engaged in
essential activity
to get off the streets and adhere to the
curfew if you are found to be in
violation of the curfew
police will be required to take action
again i want to reiterate and make it
clear please abide by the curfew that
the mayor has set in place
or people will be subject to arrest
lastly
i know that many of you are familiar
with the metropolitan police department
understand that there is no better
agency in the country to handle
first amendment events they happen on a
regular basis here in our city
however today's events were not
representation of peaceful protests
today what we witnessed was unlawful
riotous behavior
and people that come to our city engaged
in unlawful behavior
will be held accountable we can take any
questions
after that you may have after the
secretary has a chance to speak
thank you mayor bowser chief conte at
around three o'clock this afternoon we
mobilize the d.c national guard
to 100 strength we'll have 100 personnel
that are convening to the armory as we
speak to support metro pd
and reestablishing the safety and the
confines of the u.s capitol
we'll also be working with other federal
law enforcement entities
that are coming here to the metropolitan
police station to add additional support
and capability
as they continue deliberate planning and
looking at how a clearing operation will
be conducted
thank you